if you kiss someone you could tell
whether they're good in bed or not are
you making us find out
dms
dating apps i don't have time for that i
don't believe you should kiss a lot of
frogs to find your prince i believe in
grilling them i'm going to be going on a
series of dates to find who can really
wow me
this is thrilling
my name is johnny kerry and i'm here to
go on a date so i mean nothing wrong
with a little flirt yeah i think i'm
gonna go in well i think so anyway we'll
soon find out yeah i feel like i'm
confident i mean i'd happily forgot to
go in a bar go chat to them this manner
no i don't go on dates you know i've
rarely got on dates what do you expect
from the girl on the first date not to
grill me
that's what i expect i'll go on first
date yes i'm ready bring her in
johnny nice to meet you johnny
yes
good looking girl first white guy
where are you from west london west
london yeah you didn't like essex boy do
i everyone says that you're not from
essex no i'm not at all my dad's a west
london cockney bruv i'm not from essex i
don't know why everyone thinks i am yeah
from west london but just keep a roll
with it i don't think it's ever an
insult it was a compliment do you want
to be from essex no i feel like no
you're not trying it a bit no what do
you think i'm trying it yeah why i don't
know just look it's like a typical essex
look what attracts it you're like your
hairstyle nothing looks good then no it
looks right i want the first whiteboard
in there right yes you are right with
yeah right you're all right yeah you're
right she definitely don't she's lying
why am i here i might as well cut i like
anyone if you've got a nice vibe then
i'll vibe with you yeah and i thought i
agree yeah see i knew she liked everyone
she's moving mad that's a big bracket
everyone's beautiful now i'm writing it
exactly
oh thank you you're looking all right
cheers ice cube what's your type
from what you said at a start it's going
to shoot me in a football i quite like
an essex girl do you yeah i feel like
you look after yourself well i like
someone with a good heart i'm a nice
girl i don't like when girls are all
[ __ ] as long as the girls that i
[ __ ] ain't got time for that why have
you been with someone that's really
[ __ ] girls are a [ __ ] aren't they
have you had a serious relationship i
was in a four-year relationship yeah a
year and a half ago we splat did you
spend on good terms or do you feel like
loving me
unfortunately yeah how did you deal with
that oh quite loud bad i meant to help
us what do you mean by
uh i said i was depressed for two months
i said i was i was depressed for two
months did you stop trying it no no it
was a good relationship i don't hate the
girl at all so how did you as a young
man deal with heartbreak i'm very a big
advocate for that men's mental health
and speaking about it because i i suffer
women all myself i'd say maybe it's like
two months if i had
i was just locked in my room one chance
of no one because i can talk about our
feelings easy i think it's more i don't
want to be a burden to someone called up
my power turn my power my closer house
and then spoke to them and after that i
just kind of picked myself up good
i think it's good to talk to your powers
man especially if you're a boy a lot of
boys bottle it up listen if you're going
through saying chat to your power or
even chat to a girl by it i mean better
to get it off the chest honestly like i
really love it when a guy's able to open
up and just be honest about his feelings
and depression and the fact that he was
being able to speak on it so openly i
think it's amazing
have you ever had a one-night stand i've
had one or two one that stands but i
prefer it if i don't want to
relationship i don't want nothing
serious you don't want nothing serious
so what you want to just start start
moving mad and just sleep
you don't have to move mad i feel like
if you're mature and you're an adult why
are you looking at the table when you're
saying this i feel like eye contact is
important i want to see if you're lying
i'm not lying
i feel mature and you're an adult and
you say to a girl from the get-go that i
don't want nothing serious this is this
xyz what i want
we're both adults both can agree on it
both can have some fun you know what i
mean when men say that
women will eventually get attached i
would never trick a girl into bed that i
wouldn't need to go and i've had it
before when i've been talking to a girl
so you have died before no i haven't i
said i've had it before when i'm talking
to a girl and obviously i just want
something casual so we're chatting now
it's maybe like a month in and i've said
to her like when i get called just let
you know i don't want to seriously i
don't want to get sticky with you i
don't hurt your feelings she then said
okay cool that's not what i want you
stop talking i'm not gonna just sleep
with her just for that reason because
both of you on the same vibe i've grown
would you say you're good in bed
ah here we go here we go
i mean i think so you think so girls
have told me that uh they think i am
here we go again they all say this
how many what how many girls have i
slept with yeah
how many boys you slept with no i'm
asking you
you can't deflect it onto me no i see i
don't think that uh information should
rather is it a lot it's not even a mad
number it's actually not i don't have
that many one night stands i think i've
had one or two one outstanding i'm more
like uh put it friends of benefits i
think sex is better when it's like not
just meaningless
i mean don't just go chop a bird and
then
get out in the morning up fight if you
can have a little cuddle
wait did this mature man just say chop
how would you chat up a woman do you
slide in the dms no do you know what i
prefer in like a real life situation
what have i done before just in a bar so
i've had one two drinks i'll go up and
if there's a group of girls on the table
and i think one of the guys good looking
i'll go up and sit on their table and
just introduce myself do you just go
some table yeah if he can watch you at a
bar
what would you do
i'll see i don't know judgmental but if
you come up to me in a bar i just would
kind of like
just generally just want to pat him on
the head like really cute
it's not a part though i don't mean in a
power way all that got a girl chatted on
a bar i don't really like the whole damn
thing i feel like i've got no game over
there why was your game on dms yes i
haven't got one oh
i agree no game rather than a girl have
one two words and i said when am i
seeing you or straight to the face like
that it's all false yeah that's all
if you see my dms and said when am i
seeing you you come and see me you'd get
aired
no you would definitely get head why
that there's no creativity that when it
has to be creative right
just don't come with that give me an
example of how you'd want a way to check
you up on vm firstly i like a guy that
does his research on me yeah that sees
what i'm interested in just to show
interest yes then if they say hi i see
that you do this or i like this and um i
feel the homeless a lot so if they come
along give them their time and do
something like that then i know you're
not just
a piece of [ __ ] so it makes you a piece
of [ __ ] if you want to meet someone or
laugh and get through no it makes me
[ __ ] like when you're coming in my dms
because you can tell the difference
between a man that's just trying to
sleep with you or a man that's trying to
get to know you yeah 100 i agree because
i'll tell you all that
color wouldn't leader go on
i mean but you can say that how do i
know you're not a talker because i feel
like you're coming with that chat you'd
have to find out wouldn't you
i just prefer the old school type of
way of chatting up a bird rather than
instagram and i just think i don't know
it bores me that stuff don't check me
out i'm setting up
would you say would you say this is
successful i don't know you're grilling
me your head's a great meeting it's a
beautiful do you want to be in beta
squad you know they're all my good good
close friends and if they invited me in
yeah i don't think i could join they're
like a solid group you know what i mean
nico's in fact squad isn't he yeah
what's your relationship like with him
it's actually good i've known him for
about seven years now really seven years
so
how did you feel about that prank
oh
i swore under the bridge now but at the
time i was pissed he
have you seen the video yeah yeah so i
saw it i was like oh my god i wanted to
give you a mercedes at that point yeah
it's like in the video it kind of
was played out like
it was over the course of a week or
something but
what made it worse was it was actually
like two two months so that two months
so i was processing in my head okay yeah
cool i'm getting this deal and it
weren't even about the money it was more
i was a smaller youtuber at the time and
i'm getting a deal with virgin records
it's like oh my god this is like a big
step so it was kind of like
yeah it [ __ ] me up a lot yeah does it
give you trust issues now
with him yeah he knows i don't trust him
i don't trust him fully but that's
because he's a prankster like he'll do
it to anyone he's a prank stuff but he
meant it within with good intent even
says nowadays i was in the other day as
i'm in a curry and even said to me that
that is the biggest last lesson he's had
he's doing a prank on me yeah he
realized that oh [ __ ] as soon as he's
done it he realized i took it too far
how did you actually deal with that like
as in man to man how did you guys get oh
he fell off yeah yeah i didn't want to
be his boy yeah i didn't speak ten more
time and then he just sent me the link
to the video and he was like just watch
this for me he said if you don't out i
won't put out i watched it and i saw it
was all light-hearted and it was all
good but in my head i thought this he's
trying to cancel me like excuses trying
to just make me look like some money
hungry prick but i watched it and it's
like okay yeah cool yeah you can put it
out it's all good hot but yeah you went
on locked in didn't you yeah how was
that for you it was weird but it was
good why was it weird 40 cameras around
the house watching you 24 7. i remember
i woke up and there was a camera
literally right there in my face as soon
as i woke up it's pointing at me so
imagine what i said yeah so it was weird
but yeah i won it so that's a good thing
did you win i won but even if i didn't
win it it was a good experience good
people
um obviously foot asylum their wicked
brand they make you feel comfortable all
the way through yeah i'm glad i did it
100 down a bit johnny when did you last
have sex probably this is mad
um there's someone with the person
you're seeing no i'm not seeing anyone i
thought you said you like to like yeah
but i don't class it is seeing
it's casual sexy no oh see this so how
many people do you sleep with do i sleep
with yeah i think that's my business
isn't it no but
i'm just asking you just i know you're
asking me so how many
what do you mean do i sleep with more
than one go at a time yeah so how many
people have reached every in the week so
in one week what's the maximum amount of
women you've slept with
don't wanna i don't ever wanna be saying
that why
what she wants me to answer these
questions on big big youtube nah these
are mad no chance that's private
information i might shoot myself in the
foot why because i just might why would
i want to be saying that out loud do you
have like a different room for every day
of the week then no no i don't move mad
like that i actually don't move men like
that but yeah i do i would sleep with
more than one girl at a time but they'd
know full well they'd be sleeping with
boys at that time do you wear condoms
i like to think i do you're having sex
and not wearing condoms it's all [ __ ]
i've done it did i feel full [ __ ] yeah
but how you need to practice safe sex
and also yeah i've used a condom before
obviously if they want to use your
condom i'm never going to argue against
it ever more time they say no just pull
out
oh my god
brother this girl was bare picky you
know what gives you the ick then this is
so stupid it's so stupid if we're in bed
yeah and you put your socks on
what yeah if we're sleeping together
your socks on there what would be like
year 10 put your socks on get your feet
out man
do you like feet then i got fetish but
yeah i can appreciate good feet have you
ever sucked toes uh not in a sexual way
but yeah so you have yeah i've been
[ __ ] a girl and my legs up there and
i'm feeling dirty i might have to get my
mouth yeah save your chest then you suck
toes yeah all right that's up toes yeah
that's what we want i don't mind a guy
that sucks toes at least he admits it i
like that foot massage well i actually
ain't got a foot finished you just like
sucking them no i don't like sucking him
but you're not just dirty in it like if
we're sleeping together and your legs
are up there and i'm just yeah then i'll
put my mouth but i'll never just out the
blue or grab your foot and start sucking
it like for
nah that's not a bit of me would you say
you're dirty yeah i'm dirty but vanilla
i think what's the dirtiest thing i've
done i've had tongue up my ass finger up
my ass i've licked us uh it's my last
day isn't it
yesterday always coming out your show
isn't he
why are you blacking up your eyes no
i'm not dirty actually you're not bae no
but like a target ball no i've got a
halo on my head you've never had a title
ball no bruv she has definitely had a
tongue in her ass she's lying if he's
been down there and played her ball or
while she's got smelly down there i
don't know maybe that's between her and
herself but definitely have you licked
us in no all right cool
cool what
can't believe you what do you want out
of life
success so what's your dream and i
haven't got a family yet but we have to
just have my family comfy when i earn
money now it sounds such a tap to
mindset to have i have this mindset in
the back i made up well i've got to
stack it not for me but for my future
wife and kids makes no sense i'm 23. i
don't plan on having kids for a long
time but i don't want to have a wife and
kids and i'm broke i've got nothing to
fall back on yeah yeah yeah it makes
sense it's like creating generational
wealth so your kids and your grandkids
and your family are set yeah
also i like when i go i drive
but i don't give a [ __ ] how much money
you earn as long as you've got drive and
you've got
some sort of thing in life then i find
that attractive i don't mind providing
for you as long as you're not a bomb
what would be your ideal relationship
would you want a woman that was
traditional and stayed at home looking
after the kids i don't think it has to
be like that he said i'd never make a
girl play for the first date even a
second date or i won't make you pay for
anything until when maybe six months
into relationship then we can start
splitting bills but even then like i'll
pay for it happily it's just if you're
offering cool fair enough the girl
doesn't offer that's more of like a turn
off okay that's a red flag like if you
don't even offer to pay the bill i'm
going to pay it anyway but like if that
little yeah yeah no that doesn't mean
the consideration yeah because you
expect me to pay it like it just makes
me think i'm not going to pay again what
about you when was the last time you had
sex ages ago yeah you're not getting
every week now
no no does it like i am maybe but you
may be i don't know you well enough yet
well no i'm not nothing wrong with that
though you're a woman yeah there's
nothing wrong with that but
just no for me why is that i'm just not
on it why because i'm trying to work
yeah i've got goals and things are
unachievable that's good you're still
going to let some stress off
no you'll have some steam no listen
do you watch porn no i don't
how can she say she don't watch porn but
she's lying she lied about her [ __ ]
getting played and she's lying about
watching porn she said liar she's got me
not coming to being honest and she's
just lying
do you i used to but i just find it
boring though what porn do you watch
standard well standard i don't want you
so i don't know what standard is oh you
don't watch point
i swear to god i don't do you play with
yourself
yeah yeah so what do you do i don't
you're full i'm i'm creative you're
thoughts you're creative mm-hmm would
you look at do look at a paint drain on
a wall no what give me my imagination
yes that's what i just said what about
you what'd you what point you watched i
thought i watched standard just men and
women
missionary no no i would skip it a
little bit where they're giving it i
don't know why there's a bit of a fetish
of mine really not really a fetish
because it's a normal thing but yeah do
you go down on women though yeah yeah i
love you in [ __ ]
did he just say he's [ __ ]
black guys
take note
yeah that's a minor above i'll be down
there for like if it's good and i think
it was salt and you got nice [ __ ] i'll
be down there for a good 45 minutes i'll
kind of lie i enjoy doing it i'll
happily say that ah see i think i think
white guys
see that's what we're doing yeah see i
told you she fancies me about she's
hiding it for the cameras she's gotta
grill me don't mean she's got a job i
mean sometimes it's not worth good
though i personally think i am and from
what my experiences yeah i i'll commonly
say what's your technique what's my
technique yeah help them the people need
to know i'm mad if you think i'm just
showing you what i do go on show me
i'll get you an orange something i'm
going to technically hate your brain i
don't you like your brain yeah so you
don't give a head but you expect me to
die on you mm-hmm
don't worry about that why should that
work like that use my buddy
yeah if it's my manner well so you only
give your manhood yeah see you're a
hypocrite how am i hypocrite should you
expect to get eaten out but you won't no
i don't
yeah if i'm with you then so if you step
with a boy you don't do this whole
casual thing whatever say you're seeing
someone going on a date yeah then we're
seeing we're seeing each other okay yeah
but i'm not gonna just do it if i've
just had sex like if we've just met yeah
we're not doing it so you don't agree
with sex on the first date no of course
you can yeah do you think you can make
me come 100 so you're going to tell me
your technique but you're telling me you
can't you want me to demonstrate how i
lick a girl out yeah nah go on but i'll
be down there for a long time just
demonstrate my fingers
gone
would you ever sleep with your boy's ex
no way not in a million years what if
she was really unreal no i really i'm
real no i couldn't give one of my pals
he was chatting to this girl
and at the time when he was showing me
pictures around stuff i thought oh my
god she's like a rocket that everything
you've got of her the attraction on that
community guys is that my sister now i
mean i never ever in a million years
think about doing that that's my boy no
way even if i was in a room and my boy's
ex coming naked lingerie anything no i'm
walking straight outta there and i'm
telling him
that's good
yeah you're dominant yeah in what way i
like things on my terms i like to be
quite sexy i'd be in control so i'd say
you're submissive then do you know what
i'm submissive with head that's it he is
definitely submissive
yeah i don't even like i don't really
like a girl getting on top find a bit
boring i'd rather be the one that's like
slinging your back again i mean oh i
like to be the one that's bending you
over that woody stuff but when it comes
to the head yeah i'm completely missing
my collar are you strong
yeah i like to think so strong enough to
pick one
no
but you're not i'm on good terms with my
ex i don't have no bad blood but
i wouldn't want to be friends of her
just i feel like they're an extra reason
and i mean unless you both mutually have
said oh listen it's both working for
both of us let's just be friends cool
then that then i see it like that but if
it's just
one person is left for whatever reason
then why are you gonna be friends with
your ex yeah i'm friends with my ex are
you how did you break up just don't when
you just fall out of love with someone
both of you all like when i say friends
we're not exactly like oh my god best
friends yeah exactly that's right like
we actually will go for food like we'll
go fernando's and have a catch up every
few years
have you ever seen anyone since yeah
i've met i've i was seeing someone after
him yeah now if he was my girl you're
not going for dinner with your ex dinner
with her ex what am i a [ __ ] why
though you're not
if i was with you but it's not dinner
it's like
casual you're still eating but for me i
find it so bad that tell me it's
insecure that's what you're going to say
no i'm not going to say that it's an
insecurity but at the same time
there's a small bit of insecurity there
anyone that knows me personally they
know the type of person i am so there's
no reason to
not trust me so for me it's not why i
justify that i go out meet up mates like
i don't have to but i just have a
relationship there because you know we
went for a lot together and
even just like he helped me for a really
dark time in my life yeah so for me it
just would be a shame to not catch up
and just say like hey i hear what you're
saying but don't you feel like
if your man wasn't okay with it you're
like you should lie with him no of
course i'm not gonna then be like oh i'm
choosing my ex like standard obviously
i get it i get it you can do what you
want i feel like if you're in a
relationship and someone wasn't
comfortable with that then yeah if it's
like an odd text happy birthday text
every night little check up how you are
cool i'm all right with that well yeah
meeting up and going for drinks and
dinner and that now
do you yeah
i'm growing in it so if it was overgrown
why'd you care because if it was mad
that's childish like if she's been dug
out by every time they can i read and
yeah i mean yeah but why is it an issue
because i think it is because i have
respect for myself i have standards so
why are you going out and being
all just getting dug out by everyone
yeah i mean well that's fine as long as
your opinion is like the same because
you have to come with the same energy if
you can't sleep with like a hundred
women then be mad for a woman if she
wants to sleep with a hundred people 100
i know i do have casual sex so i mean i
don't have nothing serious but i like to
think
i've had like two one or two drunken
one-night stands that
i don't really think that's my standard
but other than that i feel like i've
always kept the standard and i always i
wouldn't just sleep with a girl just for
the shag i think that's sad and that's
cringe when boys are just like oh yeah
let me just get my body count up yeah
please finish insecure so what what is
your thoughts on that like
in your friendship group like how would
you respond if your friends are being
really laddish and oh slept with this
woman or i've done this what if they're
bragging about seeing where they go
that's just boys though in it like this
is the toxic that's behavior in like
society where it's creating such a
divide and an issue for women to be able
to be liberated so you're telling me if
you slept with a boy who you really
liked and you seen him you don't then
give a little bit of info to your girls
yeah if i was excited exactly
no but we don't like praise each other
for example like men will be like oh
like another one and really praise it i
wouldn't praise my friends for just
having sex but if it was a really
attractive girl yeah i'm spotted him so
i mean you've done well bob
i mean it's not it's not toxic it's more
oh yeah have you nicked that fair play
i couldn't give a [ __ ] about body count
if someone woke up to me and said yeah
i've got 150 buddies so who cares but i
think it's better like if you had you
said with 10 girls that were actually
like sorts rather than 150 just random
chicks that's much more like oh my days
like yeah okay there's nothing wrong
with girls that aren't tense no but
everyone's attending someone's life
exactly i mean but some guys just might
not hit my eyes
yeah it's standard in that yeah would
you fart around someone who worked your
uh boyfriend
yeah do you want that one off now i
don't need farts no no
would you
yeah i think you know i think being in a
relationship makes you kind of realize
you gives a [ __ ] i think judge not if i
if i link a girl and she's never been in
a proper relationship i might hold back
i'm gonna fart you know i mean question
might be like oh but if she had a
relationship and she had a boyfriend i
know her boyfriend's fired around that
that
so yeah
why am i lying
brother she's a liar surely like you've
experienced that massage it's not even
that deep for a girl that's the thing
yeah i like a massage boy is getting
insecure when they talk about oh you
also played yeah so what how's that feel
it's all right all right
all the time it's like a little treat in
it a tree yeah i mean only if i was with
you though there's a random girl going
down there
i mean it's got like a that's like a
boundary you got of course
[Laughter]
what is your favorite sex position
sleepy six childhoods nine learn it on
the side like this yeah
then when you're spooning yeah because
you've got your arm under there you've
got a boob in your hand so you've
already got a tip in your hand yeah and
you have the arse there as well so
you've got better how's it ask there
she's on my side like this yeah yeah put
my arm under your head so your broom's
there yeah and my legs here your arse is
there yeah it's on the side yeah right
and plus it is a you get a free free
free bonus look so you get to kiss them
they're right there you get a boob in
your hand and you get asked or you can
play with uh click you know what i mean
that's not my fault ah so yeah that's
your favorite yeah i said it up there
because it don't take a lot of effort
it's
later in bed no i'm really not right
you just said that was your favorite
yeah but when i've been
so i mean going a long session and i
need a [ __ ] break of dripping with
sweat like i like to just i don't like
girls getting on top i don't know why i
just ain't a big fan of i was gonna talk
what's your favorite state position
um missionary mission me on top mishna
you're on top is that called michelle
again yeah it's just a standard isn't it
so let's cowgirl yeah when you're
reversed yeah but that's the verse
cowgirl
do you have a good credit score yeah i
think so so you're good with money i
mean i spunk a lot of though so you're
not giving money no i am i tuck a lot
away but i do splunk a lot gotta live in
you especially last year coming out of
lockdown everything i think i was out
every weekend from april friday saturday
and sometimes i got broken on sunday
what straight down would you say you're
like a party boy yeah but i'm a homebody
as well like this new single life is new
to me in it and i don't even mean in a
way i'm just out here moving my chopping
bed girls it's not even that but i mean
single is i've never been free from
anyone's word that i could go out on a
friday end up staying at my power's
house until saturday like there's no one
telling me what to do do you know what i
mean so i'm kind of riding a buzz
for now was you raised on level survival
i was raised in love yeah
he was just average three bedroom house
comfortable
right yeah we done all right yeah i mean
do you think with your parents being
together
it's
giving you an advantage to the way you
see women because i think you seem quite
respectful thank you so do you think
that's influenced the way you treat
women uh maybe you know you know my
dad is my mom's first ever boyfriend
anybody ever since
like you can tell he's a traditional man
the fact that his parents were together
it says a lot about a man so he's
influenced right so taking a few boxes
here johnny boy i think maybe getting in
a relationship from a young age as well
i got everyone as eighteen and then she
moved in two months later i just respect
women i just don't know why i wouldn't
be honest yeah
what would you do if i'd slept with two
of your friends we were just sleeping
together or together we was actually
together so we now you've been my
girlfriend you haven't told me this
information or my friends haven't first
of all they're snakes if they told me
that that they know i'm getting serious
with you and haven't said yo listen i've
chopped that
and you haven't told me as well that's a
big red flag listen she's moving mad she
hasn't told me but it's even more snakey
that my boys ain't told me do i mean
we're scrapping if we was receiving that
giveaway cool i'd run it by my powers
would you care about step over cool but
i'm not if you my girlfriend no way what
would you do if i asked to see your dms
right now no
why what look for my phone you're not my
girl i've known you about 10 minutes you
want to go for my phone nah no chance
if a girl follows me and i follow her
and i think she's fit i'll save her to
the saved just in case i bump into other
night out i want the ammo i want the
emma so i feel like when i die my girl
it doesn't go nowhere we talk flat two
weeks and it gets dry yeah whereas if i
see you in more life i feel like
i'm just
more the vibes more then yeah yeah i can
read you like if i got to go on and out
and i can tell in the first five minutes
if you like me or not if you don't call
enjoy your night what would you do if my
ex was after you why would it be after
me maybe just he was really obsessed
with me we're now together i just say
like listen
respectfully
i'm now with you i mean it's obviously a
problem you've got with yourself
so i mean if if it comes and i have to
deal with it i have to deal with it but
yeah it's just this is long in it if
you're chasing me over my girl which is
your goal probably to grow up to be
honest
what would you do if i wanted to start
an only fans no
why
what you're with me and you've got only
fans yeah nah i can't run
what's your fault smiling fans
listen girls you wanna go get your money
go do it go hustle but if you're my
girlfriend i wanna be the only person
that's seen you naked what about if i
got put into prison for five years it
depends how far down the line was if it
was together like i'd say like six years
and think about marriage and what [ __ ]
that then yeah but if we've been
together maybe six months then we'd have
to weigh up the options so okay then
you could wait but then would you wait
and be loyal
if i was if i had decided to wait yeah
i'd 100 be loyal really so 100 if you
was my wife or something i'd 100 yeah
obviously you have to if it's your wife
yeah what about if i didn't want to
sleep with you for the first six months
of our relationship a relationship
six months that's half a year obviously
sexism everything but
imagine like he was talking imagine i
was talking to you yeah what really got
on really got on and then obviously i
waited six months and we get in the
bedroom and it's just dead because that
can happen some people just don't have
chemistry in a bedroom now we have to
sleep with each other for the rest of
our lives
so i really want dead sex for the rest
of my life like i said it's not the only
thing but like yeah i think you can like
eventually get used to each other's
bodies now i'm not saying bodies i'm
just saying some people just
don't go what they want to give her in
bed you can tell by a kiss
no you can't no you can
yes you can
if you kiss someone you could tell
whether they're good in bed or not no i
don't think you can trust me what are
you making let's find out
did you not kiss on the first date yeah
i'd kiss my first day so i'll see you
soon on the first date yeah i would you
would if i felt the vibe but most time
no actually no no no you won't wait no i
wouldn't wait
oh he's doing so well what if i want to
involve other people in our sex life and
you're my girlfriend yeah no why yeah if
i was just sleeping with you and uh you
wanted to go on a bedroom yeah happily
so what if i was like oh
we can bring another woman babe
no i want to get grilled for this but i
feel like that'd be weird because if i'm
with you then i've got feelings for i'm
in love with you if i deep down a lamb
i'm going to get girl for this but i'm
living when i want to be sleeping with
another girl and letting you see it it's
just going to [ __ ] come back on me i
know there's going to be an argument by
it further down the line oh yeah i know
when you know you've heard that it's
going to be an argument you know what i
mean
that was a really good answer if your
boyfriend
said let's bring another man in the
bedroom would you
what reason when it comes to
appointments to men it's not fun men do
this weird ego thing in general like sex
aside with each other like it's this ego
thing where they're constantly competing
so imagine
being in bed with two men you're just
gonna get like annihilated what about if
your friends were liking my selfies
yeah they're your friends as well
if we're together i mean i got all the
time my powers girlfriends not just me
and them yeah we go up as a friendship
group so i like my pal's girlfriend's
thing it's nothing how do you think
you're done today eight it's quite high
yeah i know you're confident yeah okay
would you go on a second date with me do
you want to go on the second date yeah i
got a second date with you maybe we'll
go on one we'll see
listen i know she wants to go on a
second date with me she gave me a little
maybe but she's paying off for the
camera as soon as they go off watch
she's coming to date with me
it was a good date you know better than
i expected are you not expecting too
much
no my expectations are low i think it
went all right like i said our
intentions were to grill me but behind
on my eyes i reckon i reckon she enjoyed
the date would you see johnny again of
course he loves essex doesn't he so
could you see her again yeah maybe it
depends if she comes out of a different
attitude and yeah he handled the
grilling well i think i handed it well i
mean i think i was on the fence at the
start a lot because i thought okay she's
gonna all guns blazing but
yeah i mean i don't think she could
really grill me that way to be honest
with you there wasn't anything that made
me think oh well based on the fact that
she went in at white guys i'm already
taking two points off my score
um so
and i think i smashed everything off so
we're gonna give myself an eight
i'm gonna give
johnny a seven
you